[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh!
BRAD ABRAMS: Hey, Timothy.
How's it going?
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
It's going great.
This is Brad Abrams.
Brad is a product
manager on Assistant.
BRAD ABRAMS: That's right.
Yes.
How's it going, Timothy?
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
It's going great.
Now that you're
here and I'm here,
I think we should talk
about the Assistant.
What do you think?
BRAD ABRAMS: I think that
sounds like a great idea,
because it's the only thing I
know to talk about, so perfect.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
Let's start with square one.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
What is Assistant?
And why is it cool
for developers?
BRAD ABRAMS: Well, the
Assistant is really
a conversational
interface to Google.
It's the smart brain
in your Google Home
or on your Android phone.
And actually, at this event we
just launched on iOS as well.
And you can have really a
conversation with Google
to help you get things done.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
What are the different
services for developers
to integrate with?
BRAD ABRAMS: Oh,
great, so there's
a couple different ways.
One, you can extend
the Assistant
by adding your own custom
apps to the Assistant.
And then, you can also host the
Assistant in different devices.
So if you're building
your own hardware,
whatever, you can host
your Assistant there.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
that's the difference
between actions on Google
and the Assistant SDK, right?
BRAD ABRAMS: Exactly.
So the Assistant SDK is where
you host it with your hardware,
and actions on Google is
extending the Assistant.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
Well, we're at I/O. And
I know some new stuff
has been announced.
Whey don't you tell us about
some of your favorites.
BRAD ABRAMS: Oh man,
it's hard to pick.
There are so many.
I'm really excited about actions
on Google coming to phones--
to Android and iOS.
So up until this
event, you could only
build actions on Google for
home-- for eyes only experience
or eyes free experience.
And now we have actions on
Google for the phone as well.
So we have suggestion chips,
lists, image carousels.
And it could really give you
a deep multimodal experience.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Would you
mean like seeing and hearing?
BRAD ABRAMS: That's right.
You can see and hear.
Yeah.
We also launched Transactions.
So you can buy things
via the Assistant.
I think that'll
help users a lot.
I know I want to buy a pizza,
you know, from my phone.
I can just say, OK, Google.
I want a pizza.
And it can connect me to
somebody to go do that.
And for developers
it also gives,
you know, a financial
incentive, which
I hear some developers
like to get paid.
So--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Indeed they do.
BRAD ABRAMS: And then
of course deep for
me is developer experience.
And we've done a lot of work.
We launched the platform
first in December.
And we've done a lot of work
on developer experience.
So we launched a new version
of the Developer Console.
We call it the actions console.
Developers can use that
to work better in teams
together, to get deep analytics
about their application.
As well as-- it integrates
really well with the Firebase
and Google Cloud consoles.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
BRAD ABRAMS: And
can I do one more?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Absolutely.
BRAD ABRAMS: See I
can just add them.
So one more would
be discoverability.
I think that's been--
in the whole kind
of chatbox space,
generally having
people be able discover
them has been a problem.
And so we've done a lot
of work in that regard.
The first is that we have a
new directory for our apps.
And it's right there on
the Assistant surface,
just one tap away.
And you can see a category
view of all the Assistant
apps that are there.
We also gave you a way to
get a web URL into that.
So if you wanted to promote your
app via your enormous Twitter
followers, you could totally
go do that, which is awesome.
And of course, people who
love your Assistant app
can share it with their
friends via the deep link.
And finally, we did
some work to help
discover when to invoke your
Assistant app from information
in the directory,
other information
provided by the developer.
We can just respond to
queries like, play a game.
And we can actually find
the right system apps
to go trigger in that case.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's
totally awesome.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah,
it's really fun.
It's kind of a big release
for us here at I/O.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah,
I mean that's a lot
of different stuff.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yes, it
certainly is-- certainly is.
But I think it comes together
in a really cohesive package
though, because
you know, if you're
going to do Transactions--
you're going to buy things--
a lot of times having
a visual surface to see
the different
options, see the cart
and what not really
helps with that.
And then of course,
if you're going
to have a financial
interest there,
being able to have people
discover your Assistant apps
really helps.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
OK, so let's take a step back.
And I would love to
hear your thoughts
just on conversational
interfaces in general.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah, I mean--
if you think about
this evolution that's
been happening, you know, like
when I started using computers,
it was like a
mouse and keyboard.
It was very indirect, right?
You moved--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Wait,
you had a mouse?
BRAD ABRAMS: I did have a mouse.
You don't think I had a mouse?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well,
I mean, you know,
you start with like
the Commodore 128.
BRAD ABRAMS: Right,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
OK.
Before, you had a keyboard.
And then, we added a mouse.
But these are indirect.
Like, you do something with
your hands and something
happens on the screen.
And then, you know, we got
capacitive touch, right?
So you could actually
touch the screen.
And like, my kid
when he was two knew
how to touch the screen, right?
Like, that was very intuitive.
And I think we're at the
verge of making the next step.
And that is, rather
than just being
able to like touch the
button, what if I could just
express what I want.
Why do I have to dig
through a bunch menus,
find the right button to press?
Not really sure
what's going to happen
when I press that button.
But what if I could
just express my idea?
This is what I want to happen.
I want to play this game.
I want to order this pizza.
I want to do whatever.
And that's what I think this
conversational interface is
enabling.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
And I do want to say that I
think one of the things that's
been holding us as
developers back from that
is the right tooling to do so.
BRAD ABRAMS: You know--
you know, as I described
that, I think that developers
are going like, wow.
Sure, but how do I do
that when the user--
how?
If you think about the
huge number of ways people
could say they want a pizza,
order toppings on a pizza,
how can they turn the huge
vagaries of human language
into something a
developer can understand?
And that's where
tools like API.AI
can really come into play.
API.AI is our own
conversation building tool.
And what it does is let's you
as developers define intents,
just by giving us
some example phrases
of what a user would say.
And then, we can do--
pull out the entities from that,
and do the natural language
understanding, so that
we can do slot filling
and actually figure out
what users are saying.
So you might give an example
like, I want a large pepperoni
pizza with tomato
sauce as your example.
We know large is the entity.
Pepperoni is an entity.
And tomato sauce is an entity.
We can actually pull those
out and then recognize
other queries like, I want
a small pizza with tomatoes
and green olives with no sauce.
And that-- because
we can do that,
it makes it much more
tractable for developers
to actually understand
human language.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: But seriously,
how many times have you
ordered a pizza with no sauce?
BRAD ABRAMS: Well, you
know, that's pretty rare.
But you know, I actually
I'm for extra sauce,
you know, just because it
dribbles down your face.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh,
OK, that's good.
BRAD ABRAMS: And
that's beautiful.
I'm sorry, we got
to cut that out.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All
right, is there anything
else you would say about
Assistant or any the developer
tools before we go?
BRAD ABRAMS: No, I think
we pretty much covered it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right,
Brad, thanks so much.
BRAD ABRAMS: All
right, thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]